- Podcast Nation, what is up?
It's me Gary, a very exciting day for me.
We're recording this right now,
as the book is being launched.
It's Launch Day, it's
going extremely well.
And I wanna first start and say thank you
to all of you that are supporting.
I really, really, really,
really do appreciate it.
But more importantly, we're
doing our second Pod Sessions.
If you missed the first one,
when I think about my career,
the late night, hanging
out in a hotel room
with a bunch of the early
Silicon Valley Web 2.0
investors and founders
really shaped a lot of
my thinking and growth
and those used to be
called the Jam Sessions.
Chris Sacca of Shark Tank theme
and venture capital theme
did a huge piece about,
they did a huge piece
on him in Vanity Fair
and he goes into it
there, so go Google that,
and that explains what
those late nights were.
But they were, they were
essential moments for me,
and then when I started seeing,
like documentaries about like Spielberg
and Martin Scorsese like they
had their little Rat Pack
in the mid-70s
and then you think about artists, right,
like Janis Joplin and those, like
it's interesting to me that
you have these pockets.
I'm like, you know, I
wanna replicate that.
There's a whole new thing
that I'm a part of now.
Entrepreneurs, influencers,
entrepreneurs like me that
have done it who are now
entering the new attention world
and I was like, wow, I
really wanna do this called
Pod Sessions instead of Jam Sessions,
where on my podcast,
I wanna bring in three people
or this time four 'cause
we've got a partnership here,
you know, three or four people who
I'm interested in, who I think
are doing interesting things,
and who I think are doing
versions of what I'm doing
and can bring value to my audience
'cause they're doing it
but from a different way,
slightly different, different angle.
And what would happen
if I just get them in
and shoot the shit about
what's happening in culture?
What can happen in all
these different, you know,
atoms bouncing around?
And so this is Pod Sessions number two.
I'm super excited.
And I'm going to let my
guests introduce themselves,
so guests, introduce yourselves,
and just give me the one minute
origin, state of the union,
kinda just a nice little recap
for a lot of the audience
who may not know who you are.
Let's start with the
legend herself, Bobbi,
we're gonna start with you.
- Ah thank you, I hate
being called a legend,
that just means I'm the
oldest of the group.
- It's true, it's where I was going.
- Okay, okay, good.
And I'm 60 and proud of it.
- You look so fucking good.
By the way, the reason you
always say 60 and do that,
'cause you know you look
fucking 43 (laughter).
It's so fucking weird, like, like.
- And I could actually do this,
no one else in America could do that.
- But really Bobbi, you are,
you love that you look so
good for your age, right?
- Yes, and you should see my dad at 82.
- He kills it?
- Oh, he kills it, he's
handsome, he's good-looking,
he's every awesome.
He's really cool.
- Like his social life is on point?
- He's single right now.
- He's having fun.
Is he sliding into the DM?
- He changed his whole career.
He's an ex-lawyer,
children's book author now,
so he's killin' it, he has
a whole 'nother life at 82.
- Pod Sessions number three Tyler.
- Honestly, it's amazing.
But anyways, I'm Bobbi Brown,
and I'm the founder of
Bobbi Brown cosmetics.
Stayed with the corporation 22 years.
I left a year and a half ago,
and I started a lifestyle brand.
- You're up to no good right now, right?
- I'm up to no good, I launched a hotel,
we're launching wellness products,
we're launching a website
and Facebook Live and,
we just keep doin' stuff,
you know why?
'Cause I can. (laughter)
- Are happy, are you super pumped?
After being in a
corporation that long, like
are you like, you're like a bird now.
- Like out of jail, yeah.
- Good for you.
Okay, we'll get back to you in a minute.
- Yes, I'm Anna Victoria.
I am a fitness influencer,
personal trainer,
and my brand started back in
about 2012 unintentionally.
And back in 2012 really, when
Instagram was starting out
and I had no idea what I
was getting myself into.
Fast forward almost six years,
I now have built a personal brand
and I'm in the fitness-wellness space
and I really vibe off of authenticity
and just being real and
connecting with people.
And of course, helping people.
- Anna, I think there's two core points
that you didn't bring in here,
I wanna bring right from the beginning.
One, why you started your Instagram.
I think that's super interesting,
and two, I think you've
converted your attention
into an app, which I think is important
for a lot of influencers to think about,
not just being in the business of
getting paid for, you
know, product placement.
I think when we get to the
next group of gentlemen,
I think they've done
it as well as anybody.
Give us those two little points.
- Yeah, so I did start my journey
because of health problems
so it wasn't your stereotypical,
like, oh, I wanna look good
and I'm gonna inspire other
people to wanna look good, too.
I was, I grew up in the U.S.,
in Northern California, small town.
Grew up eating junk food,
saw nuthin' wrong with it.
I loved it, and it wasn't until
my early 20s, I started
having health problems.
I really did not put two and two together.
Had to go to the Emergency
Room and they were like,
here's medicine and I
was like, okay, you know,
like, that's what the
very typical prescription
and I took the medicine,
could tell there was still
an underlying reason,
this was, for my health problems.
This was early on in my relationship
with my now husband, Luca,
who is born and raised
in Rome, Italy, where.
- By the way, for everybody
that needs to know this,
'cause if you're listening on audio,
Luca is so good looking (laughter).
- He is.
- I had a meeting with them.
By the way, Anna's such a beautiful woman.
And I had a meeting with
them, the other day,
I'm like, fuckin' Luca.
- Oh my gawd (laughter).
- I'm a dude, by the way.
You know, so like, it was funny.
Anyway keep going.
- I will second that.
So he would look at me, you know,
early on in our relationship and say,
Anna, you can't eat Goldfish
crackers for dinner.
And I'd be like, why not?
They're delicious, you know, I love them.
And for me, food was pure indulgence.
That's what I was raised on.
Enter, health problems
early 20s and you know,
then we moved to China
after I graduated college
and that's when he was like,
you have no more excuses.
You have time to start
working out, eating healthy.
The crazy thing is I'm more busy now
then when I was in
college, and quote unquote
didn't have time.
Anyway, so there's that
piece and that's why my brand
is very much focused on, first
and foremost, working out,
fueling, nourishing your
body for health reasons.
And then the aesthetic reasons will come,
and there's nothing wrong
with wanting to look better either.
So the next part is.
- It's Tyler's entire being. (laughter)
He's only trying to look
better at all times.
He spends all his time on that.
- So I launched Guides early on
and then that transitioned
into my Body Love app,
which just launched about a month ago.
And yeah, so that's a
whole 'nother world that
we have entered and it's been incredibly
amazing and exploding,
almost beyond our means.
And difficult, yes, it's hard
for me to come to terms with
the fact that glitches are a
part of this whole app process.
- The biggest for problem for people
when they go into the technology business
is they don't realize they're going into
the technology business.
The amount of people that come to me
that are personal brands that
wanna move it into something
and are like, I'm gonna start this app,
and I'm like, do you have a co-founder?
No, I'm using this outside
agency to build it.
I'm like, you're in deep fuckin' shit,
because you're in the technology business.
Nonetheless, thank you, we'll move on.
- Matt.
- Hi.
Apologize for my bad voice,
I had a really bad cold yesterday.
- No problem.
The accent and the cold makes
this an audio experience,
which is what I'm going for.
I'm thrilled that you have the cold.
- Thank you, thank you man.
- You're welcome, no problem.
- My name is Ralph de Geus,
I'm from the Netherlands,
nearby Amsterdam.
I'm the co-founder of
BALR, the lifestyle brand.
- B A L R, some of you have
seen me wear the beanie,
I love it.
- Balr, lifestyle brands.
And 433.
- At 433, a monstrous
football, I mean you're being very nice.
I'll say football, you say soccer,
we're being polite to each other.
Community, digital community,
I know it for its Instagram,
I'm curious to learn a little bit more
of what else you're doing
with it, keep going.
- We built both companies since 2013.
I think with 433, we were one
of the first at Instagram.
I think today, we have
over 16 million followers.
- How many?
- 16 million followers.
- One six.
- One six million followers.
We generate over 1.6 billion views,
sorry, impressions per month.
And we have, I think, 600
million video views per month.
- Yeah, I mean, I dunno
if you guys know but
soccer is pretty big in
the world, it is the sport.
Luca's like crying, he's so happy.
- All the football stars
like Cristiano Ronaldo,
Marcelo, Neymar, they follow all 433.
- Some good-lookin' dudes, too.
- American soccer's up there, too.
- No American soccer's doing same, listen,
I was devastated that
the U.S. didn't qualify
for this World Cup, 'cause
it slows down the process
for American Soccer,
because the last two runs
are so important.
America's so America,
like, God forbid America
ever wins the World Cup.
It will be our biggest sport,
because we're just that way,
we get so caught up in our own meshugas.
- One of my besties is the Commissioner.
- Oh, I know he's that
Montclair boy, he's the best.
DJ's the best, and your partner here.
- My name's Juul Manders,
CEO co-founder of both the
companies, BALR and 433.
Let's explain a little
bit more about BALR.
One of the other founder,
he's not here today,
but he was a professional football player,
soccer player, sorry,
play for the Dutch squad
and in the World
Championship et cetera, Demy.
We created a brand, like,
as soon as the professional
soccer play steps off the pitch,
the life of a baller begins.
So it can be an NBA player, an NFL player,
but as soon as he steps off to pitch,
the life of a baller begins.
And actually, what we created
is a lifestyle fashion brand.
And yeah, we like, Justin
Bieber got two suitcases
full of our stuff because
he want to have some.
- In Montclair, probably.
- I was gonna say, he's
a Montclair kid, too.
- Yes, but like, it's, we
have Neymar wearing our gear.
- Yeah, just to jump in to paint a picture
for a lot of people that
may not be familiar with
B A L R, Balr brand.
When he talks about player
coming off the pitch,
my brother A.J. left VaynerMedia.
We started VaynerSports.
We're gonna disproportionately disrupt the
sports representation business
because we are so over focused
on what happens off the field
outside of your sneaker deal,
and your sports cards deal.
Most agencies aren't
providing real financial
and business opportunities to the degree
that I think they should.
And, we've started building
a little relationship with these guys.
I'm actually having a meeting
with them after this podcast.
We sent, and these are now, remember,
18, 19-year olds, excuse me,
I'm sorry, 21, 22-year olds
guys we signed this year.
We sent them some care
packages of the product.
These are American football
players, like from the streets,
right, and they love,
like every one of them
has hit me up like, holy shit,
I fuckin' love this brand.
So there's clearly, you're
clearly doing the right thing
and it's resonating.
I don't think, I see a lot of
brands that start in Europe
that don't understand U.S. sensibility.
I think your brand has U.S. sensibility.
It's the biggest reason
you're even sitting here,
in my opinion.
That, and I think you
smartly took the leverage
from the 433 attention and
pushed it to a product company
that creates much bigger
upside financially
and isn't at the mercy of an
algorithm or an M&A activity
or a platform or social
network falling off.
Alright, let's go back around.
This is the part where I'm
most interested in, personally.
I'm gonna take you in
a different direction.
Good thing Bobbi's a quick thinker,
'cause she's gonna have
to think the quickest.
What are you obsessed with right now?
In culture, in life,
this could be anything,
like literally anything.
This isn't about business, or what app,
like the 360 of life.
Bobbi, what are you
obsessed with right now?
- Living a better life,
feeling better in your skin,
being able to figure out
how you can eat properly
so you can fuel yourself
to feel your best.
I think that's what
all anyone cares about.
I don't care what's happening.
Our world is changing.
We don't have to talk about anything.
Every single person wants
to live a better life
and be with their family,
work harder, work smarter
and beauty from the inside out
has always been my platform.
And I believe in it more than anything.
And I'm obsessed with how
you can drink espresso
in the morning and have
a vodka tequila at night
and be your healthiest self.
- Interesting, thank you, Anna?
- Alright, yeah, so I
touched on this earlier,
that I really vibe off of authenticity
and just being raw.
I live in the social media
world and so I am just
obsessed with women who are
so unapologetically themselves
and show the whole flaws side of them.
- Did you see this whole,
like, showing your gray hair
thing the other day?
- You know what, I didn't see that.
- That I loved.
I was really into that, I was like, yes.
Like, that's, now you're
starting to get into, like,
that next place.
I thought that was a really interesting
kind of meme for data.
- You mean women that need touch-ups,
showing that, is that what you're?
- Women, just like, fuck it,
I'm not dying my hair anymore.
I'm gray hair now, go.
- I don't agree with that at all.
- Yeah I understand.
- My mom is there.
- My hair is white, my
hair is 100 percent white.
- Bobbi, can you do me a huge favor?
- What?
- Can you just, for just one moment,
just go 100 percent white?
No, not be quiet, get louder.
- I don't want to, why would I want to?
- Just for me, just send it to me,
and then just dye your hair.
I just wanna see what it looks like.
I'm curious what the big,
the A B difference is.
- I think it just makes you look older.
- Of course it does.
- But why?
- Well cooler.
- My mom has silver hair and
I just think it's gorgeous.
And I hope that I can, you
know, age that gracefully.
- [Bobbi] How old's your mom?
- She's 60, ma, yeah, she's 60, yeah.
- So that's your jam.
- So there's that, but I also
really vibe off of struggles.
I think that people really
try to just be like,
oh I have this perfect life on Instagram
and you know, I don't ever
go through any problems.
But I feel like struggles
are what empower us,
what help us learn and
I feel like owning it,
and being like, you know
what, I want through this shit
and I came out stronger because of it.
And not letting it drag you
down and not trying to hide it
because I feel like, in
hiding your struggles,
it almost, you let it overtake you.
- [Gary] I totally, it has leverage.
- Right and it becomes
something much bigger
than it needs to be,
when if you're just like,
this is what I went through,
you allow other people to
be like, I'm not alone,
I can connect on this and I can
get to where you're at, too.
- [Gary] Men?
- Men, yeah, so I think
with my 20 years experience,
entrepreneurship, I want
to inspire the Millennials.
I think we have over 80
percent of our employees
are Millennials and I want
to inspire them every day.
I think that is one of
the things I work hard for
and the other ways I try to
build a foundation for my kids
so they can have a good
life in the future.
- [Gary] Understood, my man?
- Here, here.
I think, it's, the
happiness part, I think,
is great having this for
yourself, your family,
and employees and I think that's something
relates well with Ralph said.
I think it's very
important, enjoy the ride.
And I think in any way and enjoy the ride,
and extend it and give that.
I think when we started, the three of us,
it was all like, anything
we do, but it should be fun.
And that the fun part,
you can say, okay, fun,
and that piece is, and it should be fun.
And when somebody is
not happy, please leave.
And that's what, every week we tell this.
- [Bobbi] Happiness is a choice.
- Yes, and you take that
happiness back home.
You take the happiness back to work, and.
- [Gary] And it starts building momentum.
- Exactly and we stay hungry of course.
Every day, it's building
global brands, that's it.
- Okay, we're gonna do this again.
This time, the non-horse shit
version, I'll start, right.
You guys gave me your
religion, your macro,
super awesome, I enjoyed
it, I feel better than ever.
I'm gonna go, I'm gonna go more,
more practical slash literal.
I'm gonna start again.
What are you most obsessed with?
I'll go first.
I'm most obsessed with, right now,
the fact that Jordan, my
trainer, has this stick
and I didn't know about this
thing called tissue quality.
But I've had a bad back for 20 years,
'cause I worked in a liquor store
and what actually was fucking me up is
right on my hip point, or right here,
my tissue quality was so bad.
And your brain actually
doesn't let you know.
I didn't know this, your
brain's protecting you
from your flaw.
So this stick, this plastic
stick is my current obsession.
Like, I'm obsessed with it,
because it's making my body feel better.
That, and broccoli,
with lemon.
Something's happened.
I've always been a fairly
decent fan of broccoli,
but when you add lemon to it,
something weird happened to me.
About seven or eight weeks
ago, I added lemon weirdly,
'cause I think it was
from my seltzer water.
And I was like, whoa,
fuckin' broccoli with lemon's different
and now I've been eating it a lot.
I'm currently obsessed
with broccoli with lemon.
Bobbi, your turn.
- Okay, I'm not obsessed with broccoli,
but I could kill your broccoli with lemon.
- Okay, good.
- I could chop it up and
put some garlic in it
and kind of burn it and
you'll love my broccoli.
- But your current weird
obsession, like a TV show,
a video game you're playing, a new app,
some person that you've
been following hardcore
for the last three days and you're like,
who the fuck is this person?
Something more nuanced,
day in and day out,
like, in our lives,
there's always something
that catches our attention.
Maybe the new jersey of a
team, changed their jersey,
maybe wearing facial
hair for the first time,
like some sort of, like
more nuanced, interesting,
intriguing, real-life thing,
not some altruistic mission,
fuckin' statement (laughter).
- Alright, for personally,
I'm trying to figure out
how I could take off 10 pounds.
I have to go on QVC to sell
some wellness supplements
and I gotta fuckin' take off 10 pounds.
- Okay first of all, that's crazy,
because if you're listening to this,
Bobbi, you are not.
That doesn't seem real to me.
- But my pants, my jeans are tight on me.
- Really?
Too many vodkas at night?
- I dunno.
- They add up, those are
sneaky fucking calories.
- I know, I put nuthin' else
in it, so maybe I need one.
- Olives can add up, too (laughs).
- I know, I gave up olives for cucumbers.
But I have a thing in my
closet, my size two jeans,
I'm a small person.
- So why do you think they're tight,
like what have you been
sneaking in the last,
so like I know when I go a little high,
it's that I default back
to my old, old habits
from pre-three and a half years ago,
where I'll get tired,
which is weird for me,
about 15 hours into my
day of non-stop hustle.
And I'll be like, fuck, I need some sugar,
like I need a quick, like I'm
gonna eat this Snicker's bar
that I just saw in that news
stand as I'm walkin' out
the airport, I'm gonna
eat the fuck out of it
in a second and make
pretend I didn't eat it.
That, what are you doing
that you think is sneaking?
Or was it the holidays?
You just got caught by December?
- No, no, I think it could
be I've launched a hotel,
I've done all these things.
- No, no, but that's why.
No, no what have you put in your body?
- I'm tellin' you,
I don't nibble on French
fries, I don't eat anything.
- So then there's something else.
You've just not been
going to the gym as much.
- Maybe I'm doing weights
and not as much cardio.
I dunno, because I was just doing cardio
and I switched to weights, I don't know.
- You know what I've
learned through Instagram?
- Or maybe when you're 60,
you just turn into a different body.
- Instagram has taught me,
because everybody's like
fitnessed out, aka, showing their butt,
and so I'm like, oh, weird.
And so like, is that it's not the weight,
because so many people are
putting up those awesome photos
I say to myself, I'm
heavier right now, I'm 171
compared to where I was
like 157 a little while ago.
But because I'm adding so much muscle,
it looks different.
- My jeans are inside out in my closet,
'cause when they don't
fit, I turn 'em inside out
so I know what fits me so
it's easy to get dressed.
80 percent of my jeans
are inside out right now.
- Respect.
- In a pile.
- Okay, your current
obsession is 10 pounds.
- My current obsession is 10 pounds.
- And what's your Twitter handle?
- Just Bobbi Brown.
- Just Bobbi Brown, okay
everybody who's listening,
go to Twitter right now,
hit up at Just Bobbi Brown
and start encouraging her.
- To not drink.
- And here's the other thing.
- No, but can you drink
and lose 10 pounds?
- Bobbi, lemme finish
this, lemme finish this.
This is very important.
- Sorry, Gary, no one ever
interrupts you, sorry.
- I'm doing the interrupting.
Every morning, I want you to ask Bobbi
to take a picture of her
scale and share it on social.
- No, because it's not
about what you weigh,
it's how your jeans fit.
- Peer pressure, it works.
Peer pressure makes people do shit.
- The obsession is, can I drink
alcohol and lose 10 pounds.
That's all I wanna know.
- How much?
- You tell me.
- No, she means how much alcohol.
- I have one or two drinks a night
of vodka, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
- That means four, for
everybody scoring at home.
- I have the little bottles because
that's how you drink in Montclair
'cause there's not a liquor licence.
- Montclair is such a fun town.
Montclair's got a different vibe.
I think Montclair's
actually not a real town.
I feel like, I feel like
it's one of those places
that has like the town, but underneath,
there's like casino, do
you know what I mean?
I feel like Montclair's
got like seven secret,
I feel like the hotel's a farce.
I bet you in the basement
of Bobbi's hotel,
there's some gangster shit going on.
Bobbi?
- The hotel's not open yet, but no.
Montclair's a cool place.
- Even better.
Let's go back to it, cucumbers,
this one weird account.
Watching 1984 sitcoms,
like what are you currently
weirdly obsessed with?
- Are you ready for the eye rolls?
I know they're coming.
I'm obsessed with The Bachelor, obsessed.
- That's good, thank you,
now we're getting somewhere.
Ricky Van Veen, if you're listening.
Ricky Van Veen, head of
content for Facebook,
one of my great, like just I
admire him, such a good dude.
He's obsessed with The Bachelor.
Like, I remember Southby
four years ago, he's like
we have to go to this weird
house and watch The Bachelor.
I'm like,
like in the outskirts of Austin,
we're goin' to a home and
watching The Bachelor?
He's like yes.
- Was it a party, like a watching party?
Yeah, Bachelor Nation (laughs).
- There's so many dudes
that love The Bachelor.
Anyway, nonetheless,
you love The Bachelor.
Are we in the season right now?
- We're in the season right now.
- And who's the person?
- Yes, so Ari, Ari is the guy
and he came back from a prior season.
- Oh, right, they're doin' the recall now.
- Yeah, they are, yeah,
but he's a good guy.
You know what, he's
really goofy, but he's so.
- Is he douchey?
- He likes it because
he's a race car driver.
- Is he good-looking?
- [Luca] He is, yeah.
- Very?
- [Anna] Very gray.
Yeah, race car driver and that's his jam.
- Right, all you Europeans like,
you know, the football
soccer thing I can deal with.
That whole Formula One
bullshit, I'm out, I'm out.
- You're not Formula One, are you?
- He loves fuckin' Formula One.
Do you hear his accent?
He fuckin' loves Formula One.
- He doesn't love soccer though.
He's the only Italian on earth.
He grew up, American football.
- You love American football?
I fuckin' love you for that.
Wow, the Internet is crazy.
- [Bobbi] And I hate The Bachelor.
- Do you hate it?
- [Gary] Bobbi you hate it right?
- I like ballers.
- [Ralph Juul] (in unison) Yes.
- I am obsessed with ballers.
- Oh, Ballers the rock show?
- [Anna] I haven't seen it.
- Yes, obsessed, obsessed with Ballers.
- [Gary] I need to be on that show.
- Like Entourage I used
to love, love Ballers.
- You're just such a dude.
- Well, I have three sons and two nephews.
- You're a fuckin' dude.
I love that about you.
- So you love the luxury
Miami lifestyle, then.
- I do.
- That's quite a conflicted.
- Well, they drink cocktails.
- This is my problem with The Bachelor
is I think that they're
getting more and more gimmicky
and it's getting more and more fake.
- But you love it, you're obsessed.
- Yes and no but I wanna believe.
I wanna believe in the fairy tale
and they're making it hard.
- You're living the fuckin' fairy tale.
- I know, I know, I know.
- The fuck do you need
to believe anything,
you're literally in the fairy
tale as we speak (laughter).
- I just feel like girls go on it now
just to get insta famous.
- As they should.
- Right, touché, absolutely.
- Right, like what the
fuck are we doin' out here,
like get on The fuckin' Bachelor,
get awareness, leverage it.
You get lots of love
outside of The Bachelor
with the leverage, right?
- Right, right.
- Thank you, boys.
Real talk.
Like the peanuts on British Airlines.
Oh, tennis as a whole.
Playing or watching?
- I'm very obsessed by tennis.
- Playing or watching?
- Both, both.
- Do you love, do you
just love Roger Federer?
- I played tennis, I think,
over 40 years now, so a lot of time.
- Do you love Roger Federer?
- Yeah, it's amazing.
- Can I tell something
weird about Roger Federer
that I have to admit to everybody?
- [Ralph] Yeah.
- I've hated Roger Federer my whole life
until this last weekend.
- 'Cause he cried?
- No, because he's always
been good like that.
Because he's the best
and I, when I don't care,
I only root for underdogs.
And he's the best.
So I was just like,
fuck, I don't care slash
I respect the shit out of him.
And like, I didn't need him to cry.
He's the, by the way, he's
the, like I've tried to do
a little bit of like, digging.
He's the best dude ever.
But I've like, kind of
like, done the whole comp,
like I root for the underdogs,
and plus I love Joker,
like I'm a big Novak guy,
'cause he's like, ridiculous
and like, I like that.
But like, literally, he
made me submit this weekend.
I'm like, this fuckin' guy.
Like, he's such all-time.
Alright, your four favorite tennis players
over the last 40 years.
- 40, John McEnroe.
- Number, in order.
- Oh, in order.
- Not in order, just four.
- I think my best friend, David Ferrer.
- [Gary] Okay.
- I know the guy for a couple
of years, very nice guy.
- [Gary] Okay, John McEnroe.
- John McEnroe.
- [Gary] Why?
- Because his attitude, his.
- And how old were you
when he was doin' his thing
in the late 70s, early 80s?
- I was 12.
- Exactly, perfect, so
you're like this badass guy.
(crosstalk) got it, okay,
Mac, same for me, by the way,
I love him with all my heart.
We need to get Mac on Pod Sessions.
'Cause he like, yeah, I'm gonna get him.
I love him, okay.
- Agassi.
- Yeah.
- Same, 'cause of the
attitude kinda thing?
Which Agassi, long hair
Agassi, or your hair Agassi?
- I read his book, Open, I read his book.
No, the short hair.
And Serena Williams.
- His book, his book, yeah
Serena's such a fuckin' beast.
- And Billie Jean King.
- [Ralph] Yes.
- How do you not love Billie Jean King?
- He doesn't like Billie Jean King.
- No, I don't know her.
I never see play her, so.
- Okay, I understand,
'cause that hit your radar.
- No, I don't play tennis.
- No, I understand culturally though.
- No, but did you see the movie?
- I did.
- Did you see the movie?
What Billie Jean Kind
did for all of us women.
- She's so gangster.
- Oh my gawd, she is.
- You have to see the movie.
- You know who I loved?
Stefan Edberg.
- [Ralph] Yeah.
- I was such a big Stefan Edberg fan.
- Sure, he's (mumbles) player.
One of the last, I think.
- He was so, like, smooth.
He was McEnroe style.
I was a big Stefan Edberg fan.
What about Boris Becker, when
he was 18 and won Wimbledon?
- He was 16, he won Wimbledon.
- Was he that young?
- Almost 17, yeah, 16 and
nine months or something.
- I think he was 17,
right, oh he was 16, huh.
That was unbelievable.
You know who I hated?
Ivan Lendl.
You know why?
'Cause he destroyed McEnroe.
- You saw in Mexican,
Michael Chang, on (mumbles).
- Well fuckin' Michael
Chang's French Open.
- He was surfing.
- He was so fuckin' cramping.
Michael Chang's calves were like the size
of Ben's entire body.
They were huge (laughter), they were huge,
seriously, Ben, they were huge.
Alright, let's move it on.
I wanna talk about SnapChat.
The state of the union
of your SnapChat life.
- Mine's really quick, I follow my kids
to see what they're doin' and that's it.
- And are your kids behaving on there?
Being ridiculous, what
are we seeing on there?
- Yeah, they're ridiculously behaving.
- Got it, they're like.
- Just enough, they're
doing what they should be.
- Just enough that they
know that you're watching.
- (crosstalk) (mumbles) content.
- Exactly, yeah.
- And they're goin' one-on-one
with the ridiculous shit.
- They look, yeah.
- Understood, Anna?
- Yeah, so I, SnapChat was my jam,
when it, not right when it came out,
but once it became a thing for
like, influencers to be on it
and show, like, the more
real side of their life.
It really helped strengthen my brand
because it went from, here's
this girl on Instagram very.
- Not a perfect picture slash real shit.
- Right, so, and then I began just like,
sharing my day-to-day, ups
and downs, people loved it.
I have my Snap fam and
they are hard core loyal.
Then, InstaStories came out,
and I was like, uh-uh, no,
InstaStories, like I'm
staying with SnapChat,
like they're OG.
But no one's going on SnapChat anymore.
It's diving, it's, and
that breaks my heart.
- What are your views from its peak
to where it is right now?
- The most it had ever been was 40K.
- You were getting 40K kinda
consistently for views.
- And now it's at 20.
- Got it.
- And so.
- Now do you think that's
a chicken-and-egg game?
So for me, they haven't declined,
but they're not growing.
My 60, right, is staying firm,
because I'm not deciding that it's dead.
I'm still giving it its effort
because the thing that I don't
think people understand is
just like Instagram did something,
tomorrow SnapChat could
come up with an update
that changes the game.
- [Anna] I hope they do.
- Well I think one of the ways
to be strategic for you is
what energy you're putting into it
needs to be thoughtful, or
doing a new kind of show on it,
or doing something altogether
different, that you don't do.
You're not giving people
a reason to stay engaged.
- So I'm still on Snap, I still.
- Yeah, but I can see
that you're half pregnant.
- Well, it's because I use Snap, because
when it will do the six
Snaps all the way through,
I can save 'em, put 'em on Insta Stories,
so now I'm just on both places.
But that is giving people a reason
to no longer need to go to SnapChat.
- I think, I think, I think
there's something to be said
right now for creatives
to be thoughtful about what to do on Snap,
because if you download,
if you look at the top apps right now,
there's enormous amount of
attention under 25 on SnapChat.
It's that everybody's checked out
with being creative on SnapChat.
I think there's a real, it's a white space
because nobody, 'cause everybody's left,
or leaving or in the process
of leaving or half pregnant.
- In Europe, we see
that a lot of teenagers
are still using it.
- Oh, it's huge.
- And they use it as a messenger app,
and not for the content, I think.
- Because people are mailing it in,
including us.
We've like, started getting more serious
in the last week or two
about getting back to more
Snap native stuff.
Where are you guys with SnapChat?
On both brands.
I mean BALR's fuckin' brand should be
super serious about it,
because 15 to 25 Europe is insane.
- Right, at the point, we decided
okay, guys, we definitely should
come up with a strategy for SnapChat.
Then Instagram Stories
came, and they said,
okay, guys, for now, focus
now first on Instagram
and actually, it was quite,
they were a little bit arrogant to us
when we reached out for
them to talk with them.
It was, guys, difficult.
- But don't let emotion get
in the way of opportunity.
- No, that's true, there's
no doubt, I totally agree,
but this.
- Everybody shits on me in the beginning.
- But this first, since
2018, it's again on the map,
you know, especially because
we see so many teenagers
using it, SnapChat friends (mumbles)
wish each other Merry
Christmas, Happy New Year,
they use SnapChat, so there is something.
- If BALR buys, creates cool filters
and puts them on top of every
high school in the U.K.,
your brand will change (finger snap).
- Yes, great, yeah.
- What is your favorite
song right this second?
Boys (finger snap).
By the way, it can be an old-school.
- Bruno Mars, I'm sorry, how bad is that?
This second, just 'cause
I just saw the Grammys.
He's so sweet and so, like, upbeat.
- Yeah, that was beautiful.
- He, ya know, he makes ya happy.
- Does he feel too much
like trying to be a
direct replication of
Michael Jackson for you?
- No.
- Okay, just curious.
- Big Shot.
- [Bobbi] He's a little guy.
- No, Big Shot.
- [Bobbi] Oh Big Shot,
that's his, oh sorry.
- The song, Big Shot, you know it?
I like that.
- [Gary] You?
- I'm (mumbles) listening
to I Wish You Were Here,
Pink Floyd.
- Yeah, it's been a classic.
- This morning, I love it.
- Yeah, Cardi B.
- Cardi B, she's inspiring you
with her just raw authenticity?
- Yeah, absolutely, exactly, yeah.
Her authenticity and you know, her music
is, I have no rhythm, so I
can't dance to it or anything,
but I can listen to it and in my head,
you know, working out at
least get into the zone, so.
- And who's the new girl from New Jersey,
what's her name?
It's like S, c'mon you guys know.
She just won.
- [Juul] Yeah, like three letter.
- I don't wanna say it the wrong, SZA.
- SZA, she's awesome, she's not that new.
- Yeah, she's New Jersey, well she's.
- New to you,
'cause you're a Grammy audience.
- My husband had her on his
homepage, though, he found her.
- Really?
- And likes her music, yeah.
Usually I listen to
Biggie, that's my favorite.
- Do you love him?
- I love Biggie.
- Do you think he just
painted the best picture.
- I actually met his daughter
and his ex-wife on Instagram,
and they came to my office,
and I did an interview with them.
Honestly, they're really cool.
- No, I get it, it's fuckin' awesome.
I think Biggie's ability to
paint such clean pictures
is what made him so special.
To me, with music, I
don't think I'm musical.
Like, I don't understand
beats and rhythms,
like, I don't get excited about music.
I'm obsessed with lyrics.
Like, I need the stories,
people that tell the truth.
That's why I love hip-hop.
Hip-hop so skews to like,
especially their first album.
The first album's the best, almost always,
'cause it's like, it's the origin story.
It's the first edition
of the comic, right.
- Flo Rida.
I'm sorry I danced on stage
with Flo Rida. (laughter)
- Was that a big moment for you?
- Oh my gawd, almost as
good as Salt 'n Pepa,
I danced on stage with them, too.
And Jewish women can't dance.
- That is true, that is a fact.
- But I did, so, yeah.
- So what are you,
what are you most
curious about right now
in the way you're thinking
about your businesses?
Like, what, like what's the
unlock that you're looking for?
What's kind of the hurdle
you're trying to jump over right now?
Obviously, there's a lotta
success at this table
in a lotta different ways.
So you're in it, right now,
you know, you're in different chapters.
You're in different parts of the success
that you're actually living.
What's the hurdle you're trying to
really get over on right now?
BALR?
- Other markets, you know, we're
got big in Europe yet, U.S. is for us
always top five country,
but the really serious
getting big, for instance,
in Americas or in Asia.
And maintaining it.
- For both 433 or from BALR?
- Oh sorry, that's BALR,
that's BALR, yes, that's right.
And 433, oh U.S. is
number one followers base.
So that's, for BALR, it's getting big in
other parts of the world.
And for 433 is, I think,
stay big, become bigger and monetize
in a really user-friendly way.
And relevant, stay relevant.
I think that's it, that's maybe it.
- [Gary] Fair enough, Anna?
- Yeah, I would say,
even stemming off of our
meeting about a week
and a half ago, is just.
- How great was that meeting?
- It was amazing.
- Did you leave here and say, holy shit?
- [Luca] Holy shit, yeah.
- He's even better looking and smart,
and smarter in real life (laughter).
- [Luca] Absolutely.
- That's what you left with, right?
Good, team right, right.
- You guys all have man
crushes on each other.
(laughter).
- Was it on a podcast or on a video?
- It was video, we did podcast and video,
by the way, I was super stoked.
I was so stoked.
Fangirling.
So, yeah, just expanding so that I can
take all the little tedious
things off my shoulders,
so I can just focus on connecting.
- Have you guys made progress?
- [Luca] Yes.
- Mentally, for sure.
- Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
And there's that, I also
find, you know, just
still standing out, you know,
and reaching a bigger market.
There's so many fitness (crosstalk) now.
- Can I ask you a question?
That I actually really think is important
for a lot of people to hear.
How do you deal with being
a pretty girl on Instagram?
Like how much, you know, how much
in the DM, like how
much of like, you know,
the dude stuff that
unfortunately comes along
with dude's DNA.
Like, to me, you know,
when I'm trying to help people persevere
and put into context
trolls, hate, negativity,
there is an absolute different
game for men and women
and then there's a totally
different game for like
attractive, attractive
girls on the platform.
Like, how are you, what's goin,
where are you at with that?
- So I'm gonna tell you, first of all,
my female to male ratios.
- Like there's disgusting shit
and disrespectful shit and.
- I just get kinda numb to it.
I just immediately delete, block,
but I have an 83 percent female audience
and I'm very proud of that,
'cause that's almost unheard of
for a female fitness influencer.
And the reason why is because
A, I don't post T&A, or at least,
not to where it crosses the line
of where this is no longer fitness.
- That is, by the way, like
as soon as you said that,
literally I was almost about
to look at your account.
I'm like, there's only one way to do it.
And it's just the Mendoza line of
of how much skin you show.
- Right and it sucks
because I don't, you know,
women can also be empowered by
you know, their sexuality,
but it's like, but then
you're inviting.
- Do you ever throw that curve ball?
Do you ever go further once in a blue moon
because you're trying to mix it up?
- No, I definitely don't wanna mix it up.
- Because you don't wanna
deal with the ramifications?
- Exactly, any time I get a guy
that comments something vulgar,
immediately delete and block.
I don't want that as a follower.
I don't want other women to
have to see that on my page.
I'm not interested in
having male followers
unless they are there for
genuine fitness inspiration.
- [Gary] Interesting.
- So I, and another thing I've done
is I've intentionally.
- So that's made it easy-er.
Then it's just DM that you
have to kind of deal with.
- Right, exactly.
I also talk in a very
girly tone, on purpose,
because I want all of my references is,
hey girls, you know, if
some guys genuinely comment,
they're like, hey, some guys follow you
for motivation too, and I reply to them,
like thank you, I appreciate that.
- Well, listen, I mean,
I think Alyssa and I know
this is a guy and having guy friends.
A lot of guys also use
some of them as motivation
for their significant others.
- Exactly.
- Like, a lot more than people realize,
like, not all dudes are horrible.
Like, there's a lot of,
like interesting kind of,
like, I've been seeing that micro trend.
And that's a scary line to go as a guy,
if you have a girlfriend
or a wife and be like,
hey, check out this girl.
Like, you know, that's a place
most guys aren't gonna go,
but it's interesting to
watch the world evolve
in many different ways.
Anyway, nonetheless, so
that's that answer I guess.
- Yep, that's the answer,
I just have been super
hard core intentional about
I don't want a male audience
or a minimal one, you know,
ones that are there for,
you know, genuine reasons.
I, at the time, though my whole,
he was with me pre-Instagram
by the way (laughs).
And you know.
- You're a great dude. (laughter)
- Well a lot of people,
I get asked a lot like,
well, when did you guys actually meet,
like did he meet you after Instagram?
'Cause then people think it's, you know,
it's a different thing, and so.
So, yeah, just being intentional.
- Very cool, Bobbi, what are you,
you know, all these
years in corporate land.
How long did it take you to get back
to the pre-corporate Bobbi
that made you so special?
Your personality and who you are is that,
but on the professional side?
- Couple weeks, no, I
mean, a couple weeks.
- It took you a couple weeks,
right, to like defrag right?
- I had a couple weeks and
I started doing things but
for me, you know, I built
a billion dollar brand,
but I had a giant team.
Now, I'm rebuilding this
new brand with three people
and it's insane, it's insane.
And it's just, it's really
cool and I'm a product person
so I make products and I sell products.
That's my brand, and you
know, different things,
and it's gonna be an interesting journey,
but after having success,
I really love the journey,
more than getting there,
'cause once you're there,
you're like, oh shit, now what?
So and I will never, yeah.
- When I buy the Jets, Bobbi,
I'm gonna cry out of sadness.
(laughter).
No the journey, man, I fuckin' love it.
Like, I love it.
- And then you're stuck
with trying to figure out
what to do, but
I will never, ever, ever sell my company
and stay with it again.
- Good for you.
Alright, let's do Q&A
session, for all of us,
for each other, even the people
that are hanging around outside of us.
Guys, what kinda questions,
based on me or them
or just a general question, like,
what about a little Q&A session?
This could be a fun little format.
- I think,
a question where I'm thinking a lot about
is the next steps Instagram will take
about e-commerce.
- Right, what's gonna happen
with shopping inside Instagram?
- Yes.
- Well, I'll give you
a very simple answer.
It's gonna be a humongous fuckin' deal.
There's gonna be, all this game is,
is about lack of friction.
The things that I believe in
create the least friction,
right, it's just all
about lack of friction.
Alexa.
Alexa, buy a purse.
- Did you want me to find a purse?
- Yes.
- One moment.
- To me, what's so interesting is,
I dunno how many seconds in we're now,
probably seven or eight.
Alexa, buy this.
I just bought a $36 dollar purse, right.
- Order placed.
- Alexa, we meant Hermes. (laughter).
- I didn't find anything for
meant Hermes. (laughter).
- Alexa's got a little way to go.
Alexa, thank you, stop, Alexa, stop.
So here's, here's what I think.
I think lack of friction.
The fact that I just
bought a $36 dollar purse
in one second (snaps
fingers), nine seconds, 11,
whatever the math will show.
That is remarkable.
Like, forget about e-commerce.
That machine right there is remarkable.
When you're in your Instagram feed,
which so many people live in now.
It is an absolute place of consumption.
And we're all inspired
and see different things.
The lack of friction, I mean,
when thinking about all three of you,
and me too, I mean, you know,
I, Crushing It! is doing
real damage right now.
Andy K.
Can we get Andy K, is he here?
- Right behind you. (laughter)
- By the way, for everybody
who doesn't have the visual,
Andy K's sitting right behind me.
- [Juul] He's faster than Alexa.
- Yeah, he's even,
Andy's faster than Alexa.
Andy, give us a little update on like,
some of the stuff you,
gimme a metric or two
to share with the audience.
We're running Instagram ads
right now, for Crushing It!
Gimme something that's just
like a ludicrous data point.
- [Andy] Facebook ads were crazy,
we were getting three
cent clicks at scale.
- So like three cents to
get somebody to click,
to show indication of buying the books.
Now, not everybody will covert and
if one of 30 do, it costs
$0.90 cents to get a sale.
These are staggering numbers for people
that are actual transactors.
Gimme some sort of fun
Instagram consumption thing or
something that's interesting.
Okay, Andy's pulling that up.
Here's what, here's what I think.
When Instagram and when all of them,
Twitter, YouTube, as we
start integrating commerce,
you've done it, kind
of like outside of it.
I've done it outside of it.
Everybody here is actually
doing it outside of it,
which is, we're creating
brand in Instagram,
we're leveraging that attention
to create transaction outside
which creates friction.
When this is just default in there,
and you see somebody
wearing something awesome
and you just hit a button,
and you've just bought it,
it's gonna go to the moon.
You're gonna have a conversion
rate dramatically higher
than like, oh, lemme go to BALR's website,
oh the links in the profile,
that's friction, friction,
friction, friction, friction.
And why I'm obsessed with Alexa, right,
and devices like that
is that they're gonna eliminate friction.
Everything that eliminates
friction has upside.
Uber eliminated friction which is why
you're willing to overpay
for transportation.
Friction is the enemy,
period, end of story, right.
Netflix eliminated friction,
by allowing you to binge watch
because that's what you
actually wanted to do.
So that's all I ever think about,
getting to the heart of it, so
what do I think about it?
It's going to be the
whole kit and kaboodle.
And you should be practicing for it now.
And what does that mean?
That means taking photos now
that are already thinking
what if?
And seeing how they interact
and things of that nature.
- [Andy] Less than half a penny
to watch 95 percent of one
of your videos on Instagram.
- Damn.
- So I have a video right now
that we're running an ad on,
which is building brand awareness,
that we're spending less than half a penny
to get somebody to watch
95 percent of that video.
- [Andy] Correct.
- Which video is that?
- [Andy] It's with you and The Rock.
- With me and The Rock.
- I'd buy that book.
- He's so manly, huh.
Fuck.
If was The Rock, I'd be so big.
(laughter).
- Okay, influence marketing.
And a lot of people call
themselves bloggers,
or floggers, et cetera.
And they all wanna be commercial,
so how do you see the
future for most of these
floggers and bloggers?
- I think there's a long tail.
That's why I wrote Crushing It!
I think a lot, I don't
think, listen, I think, I,
if I was a full time influencer,
could make $40 to $60
million dollars a year
being Gary V, I really believe that.
And then I think there's
people that can make
$40 to $60 dollars, $40 to $60 thousand,
$400 to $600 thousand.
I think the market corrects itself,
but here's why I'm so happy.
You're thinking about it,
what's in it for your brand right now,
like is this the right person to pay.
I'm thinking about it the other way.
Can you imagine a woman
living in Scotland right now
who loves gardening.
And she's great at it,
she's been gardening
for fuckin' 49 years.
And as long as she can start understanding
how modern consumption
happens between YouTube,
a podcast, Instagram,
that nobody can pick her.
That she can go to the
market and slowly but surely
build an audience, and get into a place
where instead of making
54 thousand Euros a year
being a secretary, or making
$500,000 dollars a year
owning her own shop,
she can make $501,000 being a gardener,
or $54,000 dollars, or, by the way,
do you know, everybody
listening right now,
if they had to take 10
percent less in income
but do the thing that they
do when they wanna do it,
like, you know, tennis.
I would like to make the
argument that if you could make
$1 million a year with BALR and 433,
but you could make
$900,000 on just tennis,
that becomes interesting
and I'm curious about
from a million to what, like how low?
Because what I don't think people realize.
- Very low, I guess, very low.
- Well, so think about
how powerful that is.
- Yeah, I know.
- And that's when it kinda just started
really clicking for me, so,
I think the long tail's super long
and I think there's special
people at this table
who are gonna be in the
higher percentage of this.
What I think is that everybody actually
is either passionate
or knowledgeable about something
and both can, when you are passionate,
just that energy alone is interesting.
Like, somebody being
unbelievably passionate
about Montclair and
becoming the local paper
on Instagram, on Facebook and on YouTube
has a $50 to $100,000 dollar business,
because the local businesses,
once everybody starts watching
are gonna wanna get into there somehow.
I don't think people have fully
listen, this is the book
that changed my life
and like, really put me on.
I never thought I would make
the updated version of Crush It!
What happened to me was the last 15 months
are different for me
than they were before.
I went all in, even though
I thought I was all in.
And I was like, fuck, me being
at the forefront of this,
and if I have found way more upside
and way more white space, and
there's so much more to go,
oh, shit, nobody understands
how big this really is.
This, because of podcasting,
now you can be just audio
if you're embarrassed the way you look,
or you're self-conscious.
Writing, you vlog, it can make writing,
there's so, Facebook Live.
We just did a live show.
- We did.
- Twenty years ago, for
us, as professionals,
we would have been like, what?
Like, like, you have to QVC.
- And it wasn't difficult.
When I used to like, sell
books on the Today Show,
it was like a hairdresser and a stylist.
It was all, the comments, the whole thing.
Oprah, forget it, it was over the top.
It's so different now.
- And the attention's at scale.
Like, there's, you know, and so,
I think what's gonna happen is,
a lot more people are
gonna do this for a living.
I think a lot of people
are about to take control
of their own lives, and
use the decentralization
of our society and media,
not just, people are worried
about rigging elections,
and Trump and Brexit,
and everybody focuses on these negatives,
Russian Hackers, I'm like,
if it's that powerful,
think what it can do for your life.
- So the long tail will be way longer,
is what you're saying.
- Way, way, because
there's a practicality.
This is not about making
a million dollars.
This is, tell me how much money you make,
and tell me you how happy you are.
If you're unbelievably happy,
you love being a plumber,
and you make $87,000 a year
and you're happy as shit,
I don't want you,
I don't want you to watch anything I say.
I don't want you to read my book.
Get the fuck out, you fuckin' won,
I'm so fuckin' proud of you.
Actually, go make other people happy
'cause you're fuckin' happy.
But here's what I know.
Almost everybody is not
happy about one or the other.
And I'm like, wow, the practicality
of being in the place of
both is extraordinary.
Because it used to take
somebody as special as Bobbi,
'cause you had to be
really be all-time great.
Now, you can be just good enough
to offset, because the
opportunity of attention
on Instagram, Facebook,
YouTube, blogging, is so high
and the cost is zero.
- But I have a question.
- Please Bobbi.
- So I have 240,000 followers, 244.
Okay, I mean, I listen to
16 million to whatever.
I'm building a new brand.
Do I need to be mostly concerned
with raising how many people follow me,
and mine are all organic followers.
- So you need to understand attention.
So, for example, what's
great about you that you have
that's maybe different
than other people is,
you're rich, right.
You've made some money.
- So that has nothing
to do with my question.
- Sure it does.
You just heard somebody say
that we're getting fuckin'
people to watch something
for half a fuckin' penny.
You need to run fuckin' ads.
When ads are under priced,
they're better than organic.
That's the confusion in the system.
But that was, by the way, real quick,
that was the most
important part of content
that I've put out in a very long time.
That little moment.
This is why I do this shit, like
I dunno, I've known that
for the last fuckin'
five years, I just have
never said it before
until this moment.
- So it doesn't matter if
I try to grow my followers,
or should I be focused
on trying to get to a million followers?
- You should focus on
getting the most under-priced
attention you possibly can
in return for what you want.
Organic's a great way to do it,
since it's fuckin' organic
and it's sweat equity.
And for anybody who's starting at zero,
it's all you fuckin' got.
When you're fuckin' Bobbi B
and you gotta couple dollars,
and you can spend $10,000 dollars a month
if you choose to on Instagram
and get a hundred to
500,000 in media value
in Gary Vaynerchuk's point-of-view,
you better fuckin' do
it because it goes away.
- But then why not hop on
my friend Elvis Durand's
you know, radio show that
he's got four million people?
Why not go?
- Because he doesn't
actually have four million,
and Elvis is insane.
- He doesn't?
- No, because the rate,
you know (laughter)
and number two, he probably has 2.3 or 1.7
or whatever the actual number is,
'cause, and it's not Elvis' fault.
Elvis is the fuckin', I fuckin' love him.
It's just the way that radio
metrics and TV metrics work.
They're broken.
You should, like,
you're doing everything exactly right.
Under-priced attention is
getting your ass into Z100
and sitting down for 15
minutes and siphoning attention
and coming here, and being part of this.
All the things that you have
because of your rolodex.
- All the things that my husband says,
why are you doing this?
- Right, 'cause he's not as smart as you.
- Oh no, he's really smart.
- But not as smart as you.
- And he's much more handsome.
- Anybody, anybody,
who doesn't understand trading attention,
is the only game or
doesn't value it as much,
is already not as smart as.
Because if you wanna
understand why Mohammed Ali
is who he is or The Beatles,
or Howard Stern or anything else, like
or how Ronald Reagan
actually built his legacy,
it is about under-priced attention.
And that's what we're
living through right now.
And so, while these guys
build a fuckin' street
kind of cultural brand called BALR,
you've got, they're comp,
you've got Under Armour
sitting around and putzing around
and spending four million
dollars to make a 30 second spot
and like, people are lost,
because it's real change,
under-priced attention.
You should take that video of you and me
and you should run it against Gary V fans
on Facebook for a penny a pop
and start siphoning my audience into you.
- I did that with our meeting.
- So let's talk about it.
Let's teach people.
What did you do?
- So I took from the
picture I posted of us.
I did a promotion on Instagram,
targeted your audience
and then, still, I still
wanna keep it female,
so you know, female audience, right.
- And what happened?
- It, you know, I got a
lot of engagement on it.
And yeah, when he saw his
(mumbles), he was like (snap)
- And it's contextual.
- What's a lot of engagement?
- Well, it, you know, I
try to have minimum one to
two percent, two plus percent
engagement for your followers
is actually a lot.
The people who have above two to three,
into the five percent
engagement are unicorns.
They're normally the YouTube people
that put all of their life out there,
so people feel super connected to them.
I would say if you're at.
- Or, or,
and lemme give you a bigger insight.
Their audience is so young,
it's their only consumption.
The reason YouTube people over index
is when your audience is 13 to 15,
is 11 to 15 year old girls,
they literally leave
school, get on their phone,
and fall asleep.
Like, like, so you're,
that is the only media,
there is nothing else, there
is no some TV, some print,
some looking outside to the real world.
It is that.
And so their engagement is higher.
But let's talk about something else.
This is not just a metrics game.
It's contextual,
so the other thing that Anna
was able to do with that photo
is it's not only that she
was able to target my fans,
my fans know me,
they know I'm not meeting
with every single person.
And so, they're like, okay,
why would Gary waste his time
or what is it, and so like,
it's the contextual nature
of the awareness.
The Rock photo, for me, is
not only good on the metrics,
it's good on the contextual
nature of the impression.
- So I have a question,
for Bobbi actually.
I don't know if this is out there already,
but why did you leave and
create your own brand now?
- Well, I started a make-up
brand with 10 lipsticks
when I was 30 years old,
and after four years,
I sold it to Estée Lauder
and grew the business to
a billion dollars and after a
past couple, the last couple years working
with the big corporation
and knowing that things were changing,
I didn't have as much power to do it,
so I don't regret selling
it, I don't regret staying,
I don't regret anything
because that's how you learn
and get better, but starting
something new, my way,
is kind of the coolest thing in the world.
- Yeah, awesome, when I heard
you were gonna be part of it,
I was like, wow, yeah.
(crosstalk) I didn't.
- People don't know.
I get on your show, I tell,
I get on everyone's show,
I left the brand, I have
nothing to do with it.
The past year and a half.
- I have great news and
great, great, great news.
Nobody will ever think you left the brand.
The brand's your fuckin' name, Bobbi.
- I know, but it's not
what, the brand is different
than what I created.
- I get it, but Bobbi,
Bobbi, you're a big girl.
They're never gonna think you left.
- I don't care, I want them to.
- It's your fucking name.
- I started it and I had a great brand.
But it's not the same as it was anymore.
- Mazeltov, nobody's
gonna know. (laughter)
- I'm gonna still tell people (laughter).
- Alright, I'm gonna
ask you guys a question.
Can you promise me
that you'll make a huge
commitment to audio?
- Yes.
- Thank you Bobbi.
- So, podcast audio?
- Guys, nobody owns the
football soccer podcast space,
fuckin' do it.
Take the fuckin' money you're
making, you're making money,
you're selling some fuckin' hoodies,
you're making real profit.
Can you please fuckin' invest
in two kids that know
a lot or two old peeps
or I don't give a fuck,
two people that know
about fuckin' football
and get them on fucking and use
you used 433's attention to build this.
You can have a top 100
podcast in the world.
It will change your business.
- Okay, how do we start a podcast?
- Well you can use Anchor,
which makes it real fuckin' easy,
'cause then you're just walking.
It's a nice little app.
Or, you can email Seth.
Seth, actually, Seth, I want
you to write, for my blog,
we'll link you up, we'll
give you some looks,
you're also handsome, so
that'll be good for you.
I want you to write a post, a guest post
on my personal Gary
Vaynerchuk.blog of like
how you start a podcast,
all the different ways.
- [Seth] Great.
- Anchor will be one way, that's
like the simple light way.
How do we do it, how do we do it?
Then tell some personal stories
of what we were doing before we got here,
like, it's not hard.
- I got the interviews down.
I know who to call, I have
the address book, I just.
- You're crazy, you're ridiculous
because your rolodex.
- No, I mean, like, when
I say, how to do it,
I mean, how do I do it?
- I know what you mean, no, no
if you think I'm asking Seth
for the magic part, I'm
asking him for the fuckin'
the nails and the hammer
like download this app,
get this fuckin' microphone,
like upload this way, this
is the most efficient way
to be on iTunes and
Stitcher and Google Play.
He will do the really, kind of like.
- I interview every Uber drive I have.
Everyone's got a story.
- Bobbi, the other thing you have
and this is how I would
tell you to launch your,
your podcast specifically.
You gotta go for the biggest whale down.
Your first 10 guests,
you gotta go in for the.
- I got Gloria Steinem already,
I got some, I've done all of that.
- Do it again.
- I have it all, it's all
on Facebook Live, but yeah.
- Do it again.
- Okay.
Or, you know, depends on
the quality of the audio,
like, we'll do all the,
like my podcast is ripping
the audio from my vlog.
This is actually the only original thing
I'm doing right now.
- I hope Terry and Michelle
are listening to this,
'cause I don't wanna repeat it. (laughter)
- Alright, final thoughts.
For the Vayner Nation, what
do you want them to know?
This is where you can right hook,
this is where you can jab,
this is where you can
do whatever you want,
freestyle session.
- I wanna get your mother on my podcast.
- I'll talk to Tamara
Vaynerchuk for you, done.
Anna?
- Yeah, I would just say that,
if you are looking for someone
who's just gonna keep it real
you know, give it to
you straight, kinda, I,
you know what?
I'm the female Gary V for fitness,
so if you want to, you know, get into the.
- I didn't realize I
looked so good. (laughter)
I'm super pumped.
- You know, fitness stuff,
real, I'm your girl.
- Love it.
Men?
- Yeah, you know why we're here,
I sent you a DM a couple of weeks ago
and we will set up a (mumbles) report
and I think today we will
ask you to be part of the.
- I mean, this guy's a real gangster,
he's trying to leverage this moment to
force me into advisory, I love it.
That's fuckin' gangster.
Question of the day, that I
wanna end the Pod Sessions with.
I'm gonna start, I'll
give you a few minutes,
you get, I want a lot of answers to this,
all over Twitter, use the
hashtag GV Pod Sessions
to answer, 'cause I
wanna get the feedback.
All four of us
are gonna ask a question
of the audience to answer.
This is an opportunity for
us to get consumer insight
or if you have, if you have a passion,
it will be an opportunity to get everybody
to start thinking a different way.
I'll start first.
What is your 2018 voice strategy?
Bobbi B?
- What is my 2018 voice?
- No, we're asking the
audience, all four of us
are gonna ask a question of the audience.
They're gonna answer.
They're gonna use the
hashtag GV Pod Sessions.
You can go and look at all these answers.
This might be a way, what I
use the question of the day for
is sometimes market research, right,
'cause you get a thousand answers.
Sometimes I use it, as I'm using it now
to get people to finally
fuckin' do something
that will make them happy and
will bring them fruitfulness.
So my question to the audience
in wrapping up Pod Sessions number two is,
what is your, the audience,
2018 Voice Strategy?
Bobbi, what is your
question for the audience?
- My question would be,
what is the one or two things that
would make your life different?
What could simplify what
you're doing right now?
- Simplify, love it.
- I wanna know what are the
one or two things that are
causing people's struggle to overtake them
and not allow them to move past them?
- What's the one or two
struggles that have more leverage
right now, why are you on
defense instead of offense?
BALR?
- Yeah, a question for BALR exactly.
Like, what is your favorite
online platform to buy apparel?
- Love that, that's a great question.
- And why?
- Love that, great.
Gang, thank you.
- Thanks Gar.
- Thank you very much.
- Awesome.
- Thank you.
- Great job.
- Yeah of course, lack,
lack of fuckin' friction.
- Amazon.
- Lack of fuckin' friction (finger snaps).
(upbeat electronic music)